I was talking about my parenting skills
Jay the very competitive person even
with my kids playing Candyland and you
know running an eraser at how did you
treat your son in playing basketball in
letting him win or be in the game you
know I don't remember actually letting
him win but we didn't we didn't play all
that much together we might have played
horse what I do remember is we went to a
father-son camp one time that skip
Prosser was a really close friend of
mine and he asked me I did a favor for
him and and he asked me hey bring your
son to my father son camp so I did it
and when we were competing in these
father/son Yvette's know you're with a
bunch of dads that frankly weren't in
the best of shape and so I was trying to
think I kind of took it easy on some
guys because I didn't want to see some
of my friends have a heart attack or
something and my kid jumped me I mean he
was so mad that I wasn't going full
blast and I'm like dude relax and you
know like when a kid you know it is what
a kid thinks winning a camp is the most
important thing in the world I was like
man I just want to get out of here
without getting injured that's my goal
did you have a hard time turning it off
though when you were done playing
basketball yeah I did a little bit
I played overseas for a few years and
and that's kind of the hard part about
about this job if there is a hard part
to it is that there's no competitive
side to it I mean you want to do a good
job and everything and you hope you do
but you go to get I go to game after
game after game and and you don't you
don't lose but you don't win either so I
I have to put it into some other things
and you hope you don't get you know take
it too far but I I don't play basketball
anymore I quit probably 10 years ago and
quit completely like I don't shoot
around I don't do any of it and it was
primarily because a lot of my friends
that I played with in college or
overseas or whatever you know they were
still playing and they drip you know
they Terran Achilles and be out for a
year couldn't drive because they where
the food or something like that and I'm
like dude I don't want to do that but
also you coach for a little while what
made you realize that maybe you didn't
want that lifestyle or that as a career
well I did want it I was a grad
assistant for three years for Coach K at
Duke from 90 1990 91 92 and each one of
those years Duke was in the NCAA
championship game I was kind of like
Disneyland for learning how to do this
but when when I got engaged to my wife
Wendy we kind of decided that you know
coaching was gonna get a mean that we
would probably have to move every five
years even if it went well if I didn't
get fired which I probably would have we
just kind of decided that that probably
wasn't the best way we had both grown up
in the same house you know all that
stuff and we kind of thought well that's
what we should do and so I just took a
job as a lawyer and started hoping it
and trying to try to get into
broadcasting I figured that was a better
route it'll be a Duke in North Carolina
at Cameron we had a poll question where
I said you could I could give you
tickets to the national title game or
tickets to tonight's game make love and
update the poll results 62 percent want
to go to the national title game now I
said the game being at Duke I'd rather
see Duke North Carolina at Cameron a
sure thing you know the national title
game will be in an antiseptic building
in Minneapolis you know in a dome and I
don't know who's going to be playing
which one would you take I would take
Duke Carolina Cameron or I take it at
the Smith Center I'd love to go back to
Carmichael to where they used to play
before the Smith Center opened in 86 but
you know the national championship game
is great but 70,000 people and it's not
a great atmosphere it's just a great
game this is a this is an unforgettable
atmosphere and you know Dan you've been
you've been there before you can't you
can't describe the duke-carolina
atmosphere because the air is heavier
it's hotter it's tangible you can
actually feel it in there and it's
unlike any other game and I don't know I
almost don't know how to describe it in
words but once you go through it you'll
never have another another experience
like it and and I think it's even
different than than playing at Carolina
which is is just as loud it's just
bigger but but maybe because there's
more air in that bigger place it doesn't
seem as hot it doesn't seem as heavy but
that the the atmosphere inside a Cameron
for the Carolina game is unlike anything
else it's like I don't even know how to
describe it it's just
and you had coach game mentioned this
yesterday at practice he said because do
you remember he says to me do you
remember you know how emotionally spent
you'd be just when you got to opening
tip because of the emotional energy and
the toll it takes on you building up for
the game and and when he said do you
remember I think he was taking a shot at
how old I was am i capable of
remembering I was also wondering about
this Jay at the beginning of the year
when ESPN sets their schedule they were
broadcasting schedule how strategic is
it that you would have Duke North
Carolina
no NBA following the all-star break and
it's on a Wednesday night sort of a
standalone is this on purpose by design
by ESPN like I have not thought about
that it didn't occur to me Dan until
yesterday that this is the latest that
Sutent Carolina has ever played except
one time when the game got snowed out
and they had to postpone it for like 10
days so they've never never had their
first game this late in the year and and
I was listening to the radio earlier
today at a former Carolina player was
asked about managing the day for a nine
o'clock game and I started thinking
about well I never played at nine
o'clock you know I mean I played thirty
years ago but but our games were always
in the afternoon on Saturday either in
the ACC tournament or regular season we
played in the afternoon so it's even
harder for these guys now because of
television to manage all they have to
manage and and I'm telling you wouldn't
believe the buzz around here you know it
looks like the Superbowl around around
Cameron with all the TV crews all the
you know the celebrities that are here
it's it's it seems like this thing gets
bigger and bigger and bigger and just
when you think okay it can't get any
bigger than this it gets bigger than
that and the tickets are I was reading a
little while ago on the internet you
know some of the tickets for tonight are
going for ten thousand bucks on vivid
and the average price of a secondary
market ticket is is like 2500 to 3000
bucks yeah I got 3,100 is like the
average just to get in price for this
whoo
some of the luminaries that are expected
to show up well Todd Gurley was there at
practice yesterday and and by the way if
it's if it gets much higher than 3100
you could be here in tonight dan Shulman
and some dude named Fred sitting in my
team but I you know I've heard some
rumors that that President Obama may be
here tonight I don't know if that's true
or not but that's the rumor I've heard
you think you could take him one-on-one
I know I could take him one-on-one but
it depends if it's Secret Service guys
are gonna be gonna be screening for him
because those guys carry here we we're
looking at this fascination with this
Duke team and I know you've said this on
the air before we've witnessed this and
I've said to the Dan adds you know it's
one and done when you get to the
tournament it's different if this was a
best-of-seven could anybody beat Duke in
America in a best-of-seven no no they
would win the best 11 for Duke to lose
they have to have a bad shooting night
and and sort of getting fouled trouble
or have something something crazy happen
or have a performance like they had in
the first 30 minutes against Louisville
or something like that where they run
into a hot team but that was a game on
the road I just don't see it Dan but you
know like you said back in 2015 Kentucky
was the best team back when I was an
assistant UNLV in 91 was the best team
they were undefeated and they got
clipped you know so it can happen in
that one game scenario where you the
bestie and you may be the best team by
far but these guys are extraordinary I
mean this is the best freshman class
I've ever seen it's clearly the best
freshman class coach K has ever had he's
had some good ones and it's not just
their talent they've got a maturity
level that is I that I can't fathom to
be this young and then and then Zion
puts it on a different level
I mean this dude people thought I was I
was you know hyperbole whatever you want
to call it over hype when when you know
they said well how would you describe
Diane Williamson and my response was oh
my god
and and you know people get it now
get it he's like he's like putting a
Mack truck in a ballet performance and
you go hey it works man this guy's good
this guy's good at this you can't
believe how nimble he is given his size
and explosiveness he's an incredible
play and the numbers he's putting up are
historic
you know he's you know averaging like
twenty four game in conference play
shooting 70% it's crazy
what he's doing and and he's I think
he's gonna get better when he starts
shooting it better
how you gonna guard this guy like if you
don't crowd him Dan yeah like you know
let's say a non shooter you step off him
a few stops and give him some space he's
taken up that space and you got a crowd
him like he could shoot it because
because he'll take that space up and
he'll be gone you won't have any anyway
it stopped I was talking to Chris Webber
you know when you had the Fab five
admission and he said well the
difference with the Duke freshman
they're not facing veteran teams he said
when we came in to college at Michigan
we're facing guys who had been in
college for two or three years you know
Duke was a veteran team when they were
facing them so I know it's hard to
compare and contrast but you know Webber
does have a valid argument that that
team was just as talented because of
what they were facing night in and night
out as opposed to Duke your best teams
you know you're probably facing one in
donor's so you think that this Duke team
couldn't handle like Kevin Salvadori and
Henrik rhodol and Hendrick you don't
think you don't think they can handle
that no I don't think thanks like look
Chris Chris Webber is a Hall of Famer
and to be able to say somebody is some
classes as good as them I don't think is
insulting to them because I do think
everything gets the idea that everything
in America gets better over time except
basketball players I find ridiculous and
I'll tell you one thing like I don't
think any member of the Fab five would
entertain the idea that anybody before
them was as good as they were do you
think they would like if you said wait a
minute man the classes the the freshman
classes in the 1960s played against
better players and they played against
guys that sucker
they would never entertain that they
would never listen to it so the idea
that 30 years later players players are
not or could not be better
the average players better never it's
not you can be better you can be more
talented but I'm saying Michigan went
against veteran teams where no it's
actually didn't win at this point in the
season when Michigan played they'd lost
eight games and they didn't win the big
10 those years they were there they went
to the title game twice they were great
like nobody's arguing they weren't great
but but the idea that these guys like
it's not a crazy statement to say these
guys are just as good if not better
because I think they are and when they
have when they have a body of work with
them later on in their careers when
they're older then people are going to
realize just how freaking good these
guys are because to have to have rj
barrett average in 22 zion average in
like 23 24 in conference play the last
game they played zion at 32 against NC
state which has some veteran players and
and RJ Barrett had a triple-double
I mean without a turnover that just
doesn't happen that's extraordinary what
these guys are doing and look I I'm not
I'm not trying to diminish in any way
the Fab five what I'm trying to do is
say just how good these guys are
it's historic and and I've never seen
anything quite like it it's crazy but
you know when the season started I was
watching Barrett and he felt like he was
you know like a larger version of Hardin
like he could get his shot outside
inside but I also looked at the
marketing of Zion Williamson that I
didn't know if he would be better a
better pro than RJ Barrett but as you've
seen them develop in their freshman year
going into the NBA is Zion obviously the
best player you can market but is he a
better player going into the NBA than RJ
Barrett is that's that's the question
and I have not given up on the idea that
RJ Barrett would be the better number
one pick I don't I don't know that I
would do that but I I happen to think
that they built for the NBA he's a he's
a much better shooter and I think his
shot is going to improve kind of like
Harden's did if you remember when hardin
came out of arizona state it we weren't
touting the fact that he was a great
shooter and he has certainly turned into
that and a spectacular offensive player
he could do everything well this guy
can't do and he rebounds his position he
can play the point ridiculously talented
getting to the basket and finishing and
and if he weren't playing with zion
williamson he'd be the lead story in
everything we were doing this year it's
just Williamson is one of these very few
times will you see somebody this this
extraordinarily talented and and a guy
that is truly unique that's taken all
the air out of the room and and to his
credit Barrett has not one ounce of
jealousy in him which is which I think
it's extraordinary that he was the
presumptive number one pick coming into
the season and now it seems like
everybody saying no it's not even close
at Zion which I don't agree with I think
it is close but but doesn't seem to
bother RJ Barrett one bit have fun
tonight J if you decide to go and take
part in the broadcast
yeah just like Antonio Brown if you if
you have an offer for my feet hit my
phone Thank You Jay that's a Jay Bilas
ESPN college basketball analyst for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]